[Música]
boa tarde gente tudo bem eu acho que faz
dez anos desde que eu saí pegar esse
fosse o dez anos atrás aqui com o
microfone da madonna para falando para
vocês eu acho que a desmaiar na hora
então vamos ver se vai funcionar
é eu vim falar um pouquinho pra vocês
hoje sobre educação com emoção é eu
acredito muito nisso e eu quero
compartilhar um pouquinho com vocês
porque eu acho que é importante é esse
aqui marcado sou eu quando tinha mais ou
menos uns oito anos é não trouxe mais
fotos do php eu quis poupar vocês meu
cabelo os 16 anos de idade
e esse é o momento que mais gostava
quando estava no colégio quero educação
física porque o resto para mim era um
sofrimento
eu sempre tive muita dificuldade de me
conectar com as matérias de me conectar
com aulas que pra mim não fazia um
sentido na época e o sentimento que eu
tinha mais ou menos quando entrava numa
aula de física era esse
eu não sabia se era desespero será medo
se eu não conseguia me conectar com o
assunto
eu só sei que alguma coisa ele não fazia
muito sentido para mim alguma coisa não
estava certa que eu não entendia como é
que aquilo e realmente ajudar na minha
vida é então logo eu não não era muito
engajado com algumas aulas que eu não
consegui identificar muito
acontece que quando era novo eu tinha eu
tenho um primo que ele tocava violão e
eu passava o verão inteiro com ele o
escutando ele tocar violão
ele me mostrava muitas bandas de rock e
eu comecei a tomar gosto e eu comecei a
me interessar muito por tocar violão é
eu comecei a fazer aula comprei um
violão era muito dedicado na aula só que
a aula é o suficiente pra mim quando
chegava em casa
imprimir várias cifras ficava tocando a
tarde inteira aprendi uma música atrás
da outra e era era mais motivação do que
eu precisava somente empatar na aula
quando fiquei um pouco mais velho eu
também comecei a me apaixonar por
filmagem eu comecei a ver muitos filmes
de esportes radicais e eu comecei a me
emocionar com aquilo comecei a me
interessar muito
comprei a primeira câmera
e eu não fiz um curso dessa vez dessa
vez eu comecei a fuçar na internet
entrar no youtube o tutorial baixei a
ferramenta
comecei a mexer e quando eu vi eu
começava a editar um vídeo dez horas da
noite era quatro e meia da manhã e eu
tava assim me divertindo sem ver a hora
passar no ritmo do flu e aprendendo
sozinho então fazendo esse paralelo o
que eu aprendi quando olha para trás é
que eu nunca gostei de estudar era um
sofrimento para mim quando eu começava a
ler um livro
quando começava a estudar para a prova
qualquer coisa que passasse à minha
frente era motivo para eu sair
passava borboleta atrás então com as
minhas outras experiências e eu aprendi
que eu gostava muito de aprender e isso
pode não fazer muito sentido mas pra mim
estudar é muito diferente de aprender é
o que eu quero falar com isso é que o
modelo de educação como a gente conhece
hoje em dia a educação tradicional
ela foi criada em outro contexto ela foi
criada durante a revolução industrial
ela tinha um objetivo muito claro que
era criar e desenvolver novos
funcionários para as fábricas
então ela tinha um modelo que era
burocrático sistemático padronizado e
ela ajudava ela ensinava que a gente é
memorizar se ideias pré concebidas de
outras pessoas através de interlocutores
professores que muitas vezes não eram
não estavam tão interessados não estavam
motivados ali e de forma padronizada
ou seja não importa o que você gosta não
importa o que eu gostasse todo mundo
recebi a mesma informação
então nesse modelo de educação a função
principal é informar é trazer informação
é e esse é o papel dos professores dos
livros e tudo mais
só que a gente está vivendo na era da
informação como a gente viu é nosso
mestre de cerimônias aqui aprendeu o no
tutorial de yoga e tava passando tava
dando uma aula de yoga pra vocês um
momento
isso quer dizer que todo mundo tem
acesso a qualquer informação
praticamente toda a informação do mundo
na palma da nossa mão a qualquer momento
e santana a mente
então será que faz sentido ainda a gente
botar a responsabilidade de trazer
informação num professor
num livro numa mochila sendo que toda a
informação do mundo ela tá
instantaneamente na nossa mão
será que não seria mais inteligente a
gente é o colar nosso cérebro no hd do
nosso computador e poderia sair a
qualquer momento
então será que faz sentido ainda as
escolas proibirem os celulares em sala
de aula
será que a ferramenta que atrapalhou a
gente não tá usando da forma certa é tem
uma frase do joe é de 8 que ele é o
diretor do emitir do media lab que ele
fala que a educação é o que os outros
fazem com você passa pra você e
aprendizagem é o que você causa a si
mesmo e quando vi isso pra mim não está
lá pra mim fez muito sentido porque a
educação é um processo externo não
voluntário e passiva
você recebe aquela informação você pode
fazer alguma coisa aquilo ou não e
aprendizagem a um processo interno
voluntário e ativo
são dois processos diferentes que eles
podem coexistir
ou eles podem atuar de forma
independente dá pra ter aprendizado sem
educação você atrás das informações que
você quer você aprendendo com vários
aspectos diferentes da sua vida dá pra
ter educação e aprendizado que é quando
aquilo tem a barreira e na comunicação
como a informação está sendo passada mas
ela não está sendo recebida e processada
e dá para ter os dois que aí pra mim
pelo menos é o melhor dos cenários
só que tem um detalhe que pra ter
aprendizado tem que ter engajamento a
gente não consegue aprender alguma coisa
se a gente não tiver engajado
comprometido com vontade de aprender
aquilo pode ficar 15 horas na sala de
aula sendo bombardeado por aquele
conteúdo e se você não tiver depois que
você não vai aprender
tá mas se a função principal da educação
é informar e agora a informação está em
todo lugar a qualquer momento
qual que é a nova função da educação e
aqui eu vou trazer a minha visão é um
recorte da minha visão podem ter várias
várias funções
mas eu acredito que uma função muito
importante a inspirar a inspiração era
menos pesado em muitas vezes a gente
fala
a palestra foi legal mas ela só foi
inspiradora
só foi inspiradora o problema está não
só se inspiradora muitas vezes basta e
na perestroika a gente faz essa pergunta
todo dia
será que a escola deveria ser um lugar
mais inspirador do que hoje em dia o que
vocês acham
sim só assim se está um pouco esperados
ainda galera eu acredito que a
inspiração é muito importante porque se
a gente consegue respirar através da
educação
a gente vai começar o movimento onde o
aluno ele vai buscar o seu próprio
caminho
a gente conseguiu ascender aquela faísca
ele vai conseguir através de todas as
conexões que a gente tem no mundo e
atrás da informação e expandir o
horizonte então na verdade a inspiração
ela é o início e à educação ela não vai
ser mais um mapa onde as informações
elas vão vir engessados por aluno
ela vai servir mais como um caminho e
como uma bússola ou onde cada um vai
atrás das informações onde ele achar que
faz mais sentido
o thiago sócio da perestroika essa frase
no livro eu também acho muito legal que
é a inspiração é a faísca que ativa todo
o sistema
você pode ter toda a gasolina do mundo
mas se ninguém ficar o fósforo não vai
ver fogo
então é a mesma coisa assim a informação
está aí mas a gente não estimular a
curiosidade a gente não estimular as
paixões nossos alunos
a gente não vai conseguir é fazer com
que distribuem seus próprios caminhos e
uma forma que a gente tem de respirar
através de emoção a gente viu também ali
na na palestra do domingo ela fala que a
emoção às vezes ela até facilita você
não precisar de dois estilos diferentes
e quando a gente fala de emoção pode ser
amor pode ser alegria pode ter raiva
pode ser você está inconformado com
alguma coisa é a emoção ela te ajuda aí
pra frente ela te ajuda a pressionar ea
mudar internamente e mudando
internamente se consegue mudar
justamente na perestroika a gente tem
uma aula que é com cuzco ele é um
artista plástico e uma aula que a gente
faça uma reforma criativa em uma
instituição social
então a gente já fez dentro de um asilo
a gente já fez num uma creche ea gente
passa o dia inteiro reformando pintando
quebrando refazendo esse espaço só que
o início da aula ele sempre convida
alguém é desse espaço então o diretor
então as crianças para falar um
pouquinho como é o dia a dia o que eles
estão imaginando desse processo porque
ele faz isso porque as emoções elas são
trailers para nossa criatividade e
quanto mais a gente se sente conectado
com um conteúdo com outras pessoas é
maior o nosso potencial criativo
então no início da aula as pessoas já
começam o chorando eo comprometimento
com ela é o comprometimento com o
processo e também a olhar criativo que a
gente coloca por trás é potencializado
por isso essa conexão é muito importante
então isso faz com que as pessoas
trabalhem com muito mais comprometimento
e também a gente tem uma aula que a
gente fez no refeitório gasto motiva que
se vocês já conhecem há um espaço ali na
lapa em que eles pegam comida que seria
jogada fora e fazem refeições para
moradores de rua então nessa hora a
gente falar entender como é que o
processo deles entendeu para quem por
que que eles fazem aquilo e colocou a
criatividade dentro do processo de fazer
esses pratos é o aprendizado ele tem que
gerar uma transformação
pra mim não faz sentido a gente tem
informação se a gente não tem um intuito
de transformação a educação é feita pra
isso é feita pra gente se transformar
internamente ea partir daí transformar o
mundo com as nossas ideias e com a nossa
com as nossas ações é este sou eu ali
atrás também
quando conheci a perestroika até então é
eu não tinha e não sabia que a educação
poderia ser divertido que muitas vezes
eu preferia deixar de sair por uma faixa
com meus amigos para ir para uma aula
porque ela estaria me divertindo e
aprendendo ao mesmo tempo e hoje em dia
já tem quatro anos que estou na
perestroika mas eu comecei como aluno
que foi impactado e estou impactado que
eu fui eu decidi entrar dentro do
sistema e de lá até hoje em dia eu
comecei a viver do outro lado várias
experiências para ver o poder de
inspiração então essa foto por exemplo
de uma aula de um curso que a gente
tinha de filmagem de esportes radicais e
de surpresa o banco isso demore
skatistas do mundo chegou lá pra andar
com a galera e a cara das pessoas quando
ele chegou
é realmente impagável valeu meu dia
porque a gente vê como é que muda o
olhar a alegria contagia as pessoas
ficam muito mais motivadas pergunta o
tempo inteiro ou também quando a gente
junta um grupo de background muito
diferente de validade para debater sobre
possíveis futuro da nossa sociedade como
é que a gente cria soluções para
problemas atuais
então essas histórias esses momentos que
nos envolvem que faz a gente conectar é
o que a gente acredita profundamente na
pele de herói
a gente acredita muito no poder no poder
dessas histórias e como eu falei ah tudo
sobre conexão
a gente se conectar um com os outros com
a pessoa que a gente se inspira com o
assunto com o tema
então já que a gente já tá um pouco
aquecido a nossa aula de yoga eu queria
pedir pra todos vocês levantarem também
favor eu queria que vocês olhem para a
pessoa do seu lado forma em paris
olhem olho no olho
mas olhar com com intenção olha lá fundo
no olho do outro e fica em um minuto
olhando no olho do outro fechado valendo
um minuto muito bem gente vai acabar com
o sofrimento de vocês agora agradeço a
sua dupla deu um abraço apertado nele
nela e podem voltar a processar julgar e
sim dar calor na a gente sente
angustiado senti que alguma coisa muda
dentro na então é mais ou menos isso que
acontece quando a gente está inspirado
também a gente sente alguma coisa dentro
que é desconfortável que faz a gente
querer mudar faz a gente sentir curioso
e da calor também então a conexão entre
pessoas entre assuntos da esse estalo
faz a coisa acontecer e as ignição que é
tão importante dentro do nosso processo
de educação é eu ainda não falei da
perestroika pra quem não conhece a
perestroika
nós somos uma escola de atividades
criativas ea gente trabalha normalmente
com pessoas que já estão ali na
faculdade para o mercado de trabalho ea
gente tem a nossa própria metodologia
que ela baseada na experiência
é pra gerar emoção existem várias formas
ea gente tenta através da experiência
geral essas conexões e criar momentos
marcantes para que as pessoas realmente
é entrar dentro daquela da queda daquele
momento a nossa metodologia formada por
quatro pilares e tem 23 princípios quem
quiser saber mais pode entrar no site e
depois ela é open source para quem
quiser aplicar em algum outro lugar
alguma instituição
mas eu acho que a proposta por trás é
que a gente brinca que a gente quer ver
o circo escola a educação
a gente quer que vocês saiam das nossas
aulas com aquele brilho no lar um brilho
no olhar de quem acabou de ver o cirque
du solei e quem já foi pode concordar
comigo que é realmente algo incrível
acho que a gente não chegou ainda não é
muito alto patamar que a gente colocou
mas a gente consegue em várias situações
causar realmente a experiência marcante
mas porque a gente quer trabalhar com
experiência com o qual é a diferença
dessa metodologia
existem dois tipos de memória que a
memória semântica ea memória episódica a
memória semântica é a memória
responsável por criar sentido nas coisas
que entende as palavras que faz a
conexão e que é como a gente que tem
informação
a memória episódica ela já tipo um marco
na sua timeline
ela cria um momento onde você consegue
lembrar muito bem daquele momento e mas
não lembrar só com sentido muitas vezes
há um sentimento é como é que você sente
aquilo então eu tenho certeza que todo
mundo aqui lembra onde foi seu primeiro
beijo mas que lembrar eu acho que todo
mundo sente aquela angústia na barriga
dá aquele frio a nossa tá fazendo tudo
errado
então o que a gente tenta fazer a
perestroika é misturar essas duas
memórias é através de uma memória
episódica agente relacionar isso com o
aprendizado com informação e assim você
acessa mais facilmente essa informação
que você aprendeu tanto na nossa sala de
aula
então é por isso que o se a gente vai
falar sobre gestão de pessoas gestão de
um negócio a gente chama um mestre de
bateria para falar como é que acontece
ali na sapucaí com o bicho pegando com a
bateria atrasada com cara dando nota
como é que ele faz pra gerir a sua
equipe e ele faz
a experiência com isso a gente vai falar
sobre empreendedorismo a gente cria um
jogo baseado no banco imobiliário que o
petrópolis que a gente fala ou a aula
inteira é um jogo onde a gente vai
passar de casa a casa para falar sobre
como a lógica de empreender no brasil é
um passo de cada vez ea gente transforma
isso a experiência numa tese numa
techline e você vai conseguir fixar isso
muito melhor
isso a gente fala sobre a economia
criativa a economia da experiência a
gente que mal há surpresa onde os alunos
chegam acham que é mais uma aula normal
ea gente transforma a sala de aula na
experiência completamente inofensiva
ele chegou vendados achando que a bala
normal ea gente faz vários estímulos
sensoriais e quando eles tiram as vendas
eles estão junto com o chapeleiro com
alice e porque a gente faz isso porque é
muito mais divertido é muito mais
divertido a gente aprende muito melhor
quando a gente está num ambiente alegre
no ambiente inspirador no ambiente que
faz a gente pensar e faz a gente é
sentir por dentro de verdade
então é isso que a gente tenta trazer em
todas as aulas da perestroika um
ambiente leve onde aprender é legal e
mais importante do que isso é a gente
não acha que ao final do curso é o fim
da jornada na pré histórica a gente
trazendo inspiração para o dia a dia dos
alunos a gente fazendo inspiração para o
nosso dia a dia isso é só o início da
jornada na verdade porque eu tenho
certeza que alguém que saia um brilho no
olhar de um curso
ela vai correr muito atrás da informação
de complementar e de aplicar tudo aquilo
que ela aprendeu a língua
então por isso que eu falo que a
educação ela tem que ter transformação
se ela não tiver transformação alguma
coisa ele teve ruído porque a gente tem
que inspirar as pessoas para elas
mudarem e mudarem o ambiente ao redor
por isso que acredito muito nisso que
pessoas apaixonadas uma pessoa
apaixonante
é diferente quando a gente olha no olho
de alguém que realmente apaixonado pelo
que faz e tem aquele brilho no olhar e
você consegue se conectar muito mais
fácil essa pessoa
então eu queria para terminar
já falei muito do que a gente
gente como a gente faz experiências e
como é que a gente tenta criar essa
moção para a retenção de conteúdo
espero que eu tenha conseguido esperar
um pouquinho vocês hoje muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]